[Musique]
le Sénat compte 348 sénateurs et leurs
principales missions est de participer
au travail législatif pour cela il
dépose des propositions de loi ou
présente des amendements au texte
discutés en commission ou en séance
publique une fois la loi votée le Sénat
peut avec le soutien de 60 sénateurs au
minimum saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel afin qu'ils se prononce
sur la conformité du texte ou non à la
constitution les sénateurs ont également
pour mission de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement et pour cela il dispose de
différents outils
il y a la question écrite ou orale qui
permet d'interpeller directement les
membres du gouvernement sur un sujet en
particulier ou encore la mission
d'information au sein de laquelle un
groupe de sénateurs travaille sur un
thème spécifique avec des auditions et
des déplacements sur le terrain si le
sujet concerne la gestion d'un service
public ou des faits particulièrement
graves les sénateurs peuvent ouvrir une
commission d'enquête celle-ci offre des
moyens d'investigation plus importants
et leur permet donc d'obtenir davantage
d'informations
un sénateur ne peut être membre que
d'une seule commission permanente mais
il peut également travailler au sein de
la commission des affaires européennes
de l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation
des choix scientifiques et
technologiques ou de l'une des
délégations du Sénat contrairement au
députés les sénateurs ne peuvent pas
remettre en cause la responsabilité du
gouvernement cependant contrairement à
l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat ne peut
pas être dissout nous votons pour les
députés mais qui élit les sénateurs les
sénateurs sont élus pour 6 ans au
suffrage universel indirect c'est à dire
par 162.000 grands électeurs qui sont
principalement déconseillés municipaux
régionaux et départementaux mais aussi
des députés et des sénateurs
les élections sont organisées tous les
trois ans pour renouveler le Sénat par
moitié et le nombre de sénateurs élus
dans chaque circonscription varie en
fonction de la population un sénateur
pour la Lozère 5 dans le Bas-Rhin 12 à
Paris etc les sénateurs partagent leur
semaine entre leur activité en
circonscription et le travail législatif
s'ils ne sont pas assez assidus au Sénat
ils sont sanctionnés financièrement
aujourd'hui 35% des sénateurs sont des
femmes et le plus jeune sénateur a été
élu à l'âge de 26 ans
[Musique]